[Music]
skyscrapers missiles cigars war
memorials post boxes all examples of the
thrusting virile long lasting stamina of
male achievement cannily celebrating a
specific part of the male body Paulo
centrosome
is the idea that the phallus or the
penis is central to the human experience
not just the phallus on its own of
course but also that luckiest of people
in the world an owner of a phallus a
proper person a man why are sick men
fight obviously men knows and women who
disagree are just envious they probably
secretly wish they had one too
why settle for a fake he argued when you
can have a banana or a cucumber or a
stick of salami the actual word Paulo
centrosome was coined by Welsh
psychoanalyst Alfred Ernest Jones he was
a close friend and biographer of Lloyd
but disagreed with Freud's theory if
anything he argued his belief that women
were so envious of men things revealed
far more by Freud than a secret female
plot relaxed he told his friend no woman
is going to sneak up and steal your
little segment so he created the phrase
fallow centrosome to criticize his
Austrian friends penis based paranoia
the phrase was later picked up by
feminists to articulate the experience
of living in a patriarchal society and
its obsession with the male view gaze
and audience
the man experience in our culture is the
default the homescreen the universal the
factory session they argued in reaction
to this female artists began to create
their own work that articulated the
female experience and created works that
celebrate the curves of the female
reproductive parts they also reclaimed
earlier ancient works of art and
celebrated female power all to remind
the Freudians of this world women are
perfectly happy living penis free lives
sometimes a cigar is just a cigar
you